when you met Leila I remember you guys
got married not because you guys were in
love can you talk about that yeah 100 I
think I like our Dynamic a lot every
relationship I had prior to this he was
like you meet somebody you feel some
chemistry and then it gets hot and heavy
really quickly it starts to cool down a
little bit and then you look up and
you're like you know we actually don't
have a lot of things in common besides
the fact that we're opposite which is
why we attract and begin with we did a
different experience we went on our
first date and we ended up talking about
business for four hours and I was like
cool and so I felt myself coming just
like wanting to see her again whatever I
was doing I'd just rather do it with her
and so it's much more companionate
rather than capital L love relationship
the shared Mission and shared values of
this is what I want to do with my life
she's like me too I want to do big